- [Voiceover] I can tell you
I've jumped out of airplanes before.
I've done almost every
sport there is out there
and done all these thrills.
I have never felt the same
as I do when I'm dancing.
I am a breakdancer, and
I go by B-girlsnap1.
Snap because I'm actually double-jointed,
and then the one was added because
I'm the only b-girl up in Alaska.
I strictly compete against boys.
It makes you be good, not
for a girl, but as a dancer.
Professionally, I'm a
UH60 Black Op mechanic.
I spend 40 hours a week
fixing helicopters,
inspecting helicopters,
replacing major components.
Being in the Army has taught
me a lot of self-discipline
and focus because
if my body goes kaputs
I can't do my passion.
The hip-hop scene in
Anchorage is very small.
We are so far away from the rest of
the hip-hop scene in the
United States and in the world.
Being able to accomplish
what our crew members
have been able to accomplish
sets a good influence for
everybody else that lives here
that if they just put enough
time and effort and passion
into their craft they
can actually go somewhere
and do something with it.
Doing all these incredible
things with my body
to the music and battling
these other people
is a remarkable feeling that
I just simply can't get anywhere else.